the usual ingredients including flour go
into making bread here in this bakery in
sudan's capital horton but in the past
month the cost of a single loaf has
increased by more than 40 percent from
35 to denise pounds to 50. the
equivalent of nearly a dollar
the reason for the increase is because
everything needed to make the bread has
increased the yeast the electricity to
operate the ovens and the wheat but the
biggest increase is in the wheat wheat
is imported and the cost of importing
has increased
hikes in prices of bread was one of the
factors that sparked a revolution in
2018 leading to the overthrow of the
country's then president ahmad al-bashir
but the cost has increased tenfold from
what it was just two years ago it's the
result of the lifting of wheat subsidies
as sudan grapples with a shortage of
hard currency global events have also
contributed to the recent increase in
the cost of wheat
83 percent of sudan's wheat imports come
from russia and ukraine and the war has
affected global wheat supplies
even if sudan decides to look for other
sources for its wheat imports it will
likely be at a higher cost the war in
ukraine has increased the price of wheat
and sudan will still need to secure hard
currency to buy it and right now that's
something that's in short supply
international donors suspended aid to
the government following last year's
military takeover
sudan is already grappling with an
economic crisis and devalued its
currency last year and again in early
march that's increased the cost of those
living in poverty to more than 70
percent according to the world bank many
are unable to afford feeding their
families
the idea of additional meals is
something we have dropped because the
cost of bread we now stick to breakfast
and lunch no dinner and even when you
think of buying your own wheat and
baking at home the cost of flour is high
i used to be able to buy for 400 or 500
sudanese pounds now the least i spend is
1 500 pounds to feed my family there is
a big difference in the cost before and
now
9.8 million sudanese were food insecure
last year according to the un but with
the war in ukraine and the deteriorating
economy the organization says that
number is expected to double to 18
million by the end of 2022.
already before the this the ukraine
crisis we have already seen the increase
of mild nourishment across country
and mainly because of the food
insecurity
the impact of this food insecurity will
be that there will be increased case
load in in the nutrition sites or the
nutrition services
ngos like us or un agencies our
government is providing across country
but also there will be increased case
load in the health facilities because of
the
impact of food security and having a
lack of access to food
sayed's bakery has reduced its
operations due to the increased cost of
making bread he's concerned that they
may come a day when he would have to
shut it down because even if he could
afford to buy flour to make bread there
may be very few who can afford to buy it
hebel morgan al jazeera horton
well let's now speak to thompson fury
he's in live in western ukraine and is a
spokesperson for the world food program
thank you very much for being with us on
al jazeera mr fieri uh we often hear
about russia and ukraine being the bread
baskets of europe but of course it goes
beyond europe doesn't it as we've seen
in in hibba's report there what will a
prolonged conflict mean for these
countries like sudan and countries in
the middle east that are vulnerable to
the price of of wheat and bread
russia and ukraine combined account for
almost 30 percent of the global wheat
exports at 20 percent of global maze
experts
any disruption of course such as this
conflict in production or even the
supply is likely to drive prices up
affecting millions of people people such
as people living in countries like sudan
now the longer this war goes on
global commodity markets will soon be
missing the food and prices are
definitely going to shoot up
what is happening in sudan is just the
start
more and more countries will likely be
be affected because almost 45 african
countries import a third of their wheat
from from from the region and 18 of
those countries import over 50 percent
of their wheat from the region so this
is disastrous this is catastrophic and
it will spell do for most of those
countries and so what should the
governments of these countries like
sudan be be doing right right now
in terms of contingency plans if this
continues to go on if the conflict
strikes on
look um i think if there's anything to
be learned from this conflict and which
is also quite clear from what we learned
from the kovit 19 is that
this has exposed our a highly
concentrated agricultural export market
we over rely on too few countries to
produce food that feeds the rest of the
world now the world's exports and
reserves of primary agricultural
commodities remain concentrated in a
very few places now we need
diversification we need to boost local
production and countries like sudan have
been doing so and organizations such as
the wolf food program have been trying
to boost local production in countries
such as sudan
but we are not where we want to be but
we are certainly aware of it and we are
headed towards it all right now the wfp
even before this conflict had been
forced to to reduce food rations for
eight million people in yemen so what
impact is the war in ukraine having on
on food aid there and in countries that
are in conflict and are already
suffering before this war began what are
going to be your plans and solutions to
help these countries like yemen
look
ukraine is a country of 40 million but
that is feeding 400 million
um it is
it is now caught up in this conflict and
quite a number of operations and
countries are going to catch the call
um in yemen we have been forced
unfortunately to reduce rations to
people we are struggling we need
resources the owners have been
supportive but we ask them to kindly dig
deeper so that we are able to continue
and sustain operations it is not easy
for us when we choose uh who eats and
who doesn't eat or when we take food
from those who are hungry to feed those
who are starving or on the brink which
is what we've been doing in yemen just
to
to sort of sustain activities and make
sure that people tied the times
it's not sustainable
we need we need to be able to produce
food but countries that are in conflict
and yemen is one country that has been
conflict for almost eight years now it
has been decimated it is on its knees we
just need the conflicts to stop
then we have a realistic chance of being
able to to to eliminate hunger thank you
so much for talking to us thompson fury
spokesman for the world food program
joining us there from live in western
ukraine thank you so much for your time
thank you so much for having me